Jim wrote in saying hey do you guys
prefer reading from a Kindle or actual
book will electronic readers such as the
Kindle replace books in the near future
I've spoken about this with many people
and I've said before on the show that I
still like physical paper books there's
a couple different things going on
number one I read a lot at night before
I go to bed and the idea of sitting in
bed with an electronic tablet I just
don't like the idea of it it seems way
more calming to me to be there with a
physical book and maybe the maybe I'm
starting to be part of the generation
that is unable to adapt to a new
technology and I totally get the
minimalist aspect of I could replace my
hundreds of books with a single tablet
and free up so much space
I like physically holding the book to
some extent and I don't know I'm sure
that eventually we are going to have a
smaller and smaller percentage of books
being read as physical books there's no
doubt about it
when will I transition I don't know and
then there's things like battery life
I'm very bad at thinking ahead so if I'm
going on a long trip or something I want
to bring a book with me and not a Kindle
because I may forget to charge it yeah I
mean I feel like these things have been
around for over a decade now if they
were going to replace books almost
entirely I think that would have
happened by now I mean I think that
bookstores would have gone the way of
places like Blockbuster and maybe to
some extent they are but I think Barnes
and Noble is still going strong a lot of
local bookstores are going out of
business there's no doubt about that but
it could just be because people are
reading less new technology it's
possible I don't know what the data is
on whether people are actually reading
more or less
I am realistic okay Jim I mean I get
that
I don't over time you're going to see
more and more reading happening in
digital formats not to mention
eventually we're probably going to have
contact lenses that are connected to
some device and actually just project
what we're reading right in front of us
I mean run we're on the cusp of that
technology of becoming a going prototype
more and more already so I get that just
holding a paper book it's so unlikely
that in a hundred years you're still
going to see the same number of paper
books being read by P
but for the time being I I feel like I'm
resisting this is a way in which I'm
sort of a Luddite you know what else I
like is when you're reading a book you
can even see how many pages you have
left so you can see alright I'm halfway
through the story yeah and I've
accomplished this much I have a whole
chunk that I've gotten through I mean I
kind of like that and just seeing the
numbers on a Kindle doesn't do the same
thing for me well but most of those
Kindles do show you like the percentage
of the book that you've read it doesn't
do it's not the same it doesn't feel the
same way for you all right and who
doesn't like the smell of a newly
printed book you know or an old book
that starts to get yellow and red on the
sides we have one here but you know what
I don't even gonna tell the story but we
have a book that was sent to us by a
viewer if you smell it it just smells
like cigarettes so clearly it was held
in the home of a smoker for a very very
long time we've got the book quarantined
in a double paper bag over there there's
never been a better argument for keeping
old books the way they are yes yes
indeed all right thank you to Jim thank
you to Coleen and thanks to Keisha
bonus show is next david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up coupon code
I voted 17